foreign
[Music]
while the war rages on in Ukraine a
group of ukrainians is fighting for
their country through culture when
dancers with the Keith City Ballet were
stranded outside their country by the
war their mission grew to display and
defend their culture through dance they
recently wrapped up the company's first
ever U.S tour Adriana Diaz caught up
with the dancers in Chicago
under the rumble of the L train at
Chicago's Auditorium Theater
these dancers have more than
choreography on their minds all my
family are in cave now
my mother father sister I imagine you've
been worried about them yes I've been
very scared Sasha morose and Marina
apanasenko both 19 are among 33 dancers
with the Kiev City Ballet most of their
families are still in Ukraine my mother
always told me we are okay and my sister
have marriage your sister got married
yeah and you missed the wedding yeah it
was just video chat and Marina I'm lucky
to to hear the voice of my mother only
by phone but
I hope everything will be okay the dance
company left Ukraine in February to
perform in Paris company director Ivan
kozloff said they were only supposed to
be gone three weeks before this happened
we woke up and realized that's our
country is under attack literally the
day after you left yes to keep them safe
Paris granted the dancers a residency
and they continue traveling launching
their first ever U.S tour funded by a
chicago-based foundation it is
a difficult period for all of ukrainians
but when you understand the main aim to
represent your country and you become
more strong you feel stronger I feel
stronger when I dance to show the world
um our light our energy you were able to
get out of the country just in time but
is there any any guilt that you might
feel or you know your dancers feel not
being home fighting at this time it's
not a guilt we feel sorry that we cannot
be in the two places at the same time
you know we are doing our best from the
field of war from the stages you know we
will present our country we're trying to
show how Brave we are how strong we are
their U.S tour spanned 15 cities and
featured the classic Swan Lake
and a new work choreographed by director
Kozlov after the war started called
tribute to peace
a story celebrating love love laughter
and living in the moment how have you
been received by American audiences oh
absolutely good absolutely I thought
that people are different in different
countries different continents and they
won't understand us but the language of
dance is international does it feel like
you're doing your part almost fighting
in this war fighting for your country
here on stage it's our place to fight
because our task is to save Ukrainian
culture because culture is the country
and Ukraine has a great history
and our task is to save it
for CBS Saturday morning Adriana Diaz
Chicago
[Applause]
beautiful yeah it is and ballet has
certainly some of its roots in that part
of the world so it's just it's wonderful
that they're able to express it in a way
that they feel like they are part of the
fight and the dancing and even with the
Athletics and other forms of Art and
expression it gives folks something to
live for and to kind of show what their
coach is all about so they are doing
that part they are